you okay not okay it's so different than
the person that I married I just I just
can't that's who I loved and that's who
I remember
I'll do anything to get that person back
Kanye and Kim went public with their
romance in 2012. recently um about a
year ago a year and a half they
announced their divorce women will pick
a guy it will be very obvious the type
of guy he is and then they will whine
and complain about the outcome and then
break up their family after they get the
kids
so this is why I have no sympathy
nobody's perfect everybody has pros and
cons of them and you should just know
the type of guy you're dealing with and
if you can't pick for yourself I would
find you know a brother uncle or father
because as women we just pick stupidly